- [Narrator] In Mexico
City, cars are everywhere.
Over 3.5 million to be exact
and it's not exactly
great for the environment,
but fear not, because there's a solution
that can change all of that,
and that solution is a...
(record scratch)
Volkswagen Beetle?
(joyful music)
Welcome to Alto Rendimiento Automotriz.
A mechanical workshop that
specializes in transforming
old, gas fueled cars, into electric cars.
- We started this project 10 years ago,
and have converted over two dozen
different (gas) vehicles
into electric ones.
Our oldest converted car has been working
for five years nonstop.
- [Narrator] Alvaro De
La Paz is the engineer
behind the car conversion,
and then there's Hector.
- My name is Hector Ruiz, and
I'm a computer scientist.
- [Narrator] Hector is
responsible for gathering
the electrical parts and
making sure they work.
Right?
- Yeah, I do the purchasing,
the extensive testing of the components.
If we have to burn something, I'm the guy.
In order to learn how to
do electric car conversion,
you don't need any specific degree.
It's something very simple.
After reading a lot of books
and taking training courses,
I believe anyone can do it.
- [Narrator] Hector
and Alvaro learned that
converting older cars
is both cost effective
and safer for the environment.
- It is also far more advantageous
to convert an old car,
because the older a car is,
the more fuel it uses up
and the more pollution it causes.
- [Narrator] By removing all the parts
related to fuel combustion,
they can install the electrical components
to have a fully functional
electric car with zero emission.
- [Alvaro] We have the
engine, which is now electric,
the computer, which controls the speed,
and the battery and the battery charger.
These are the main parts
and they're all wired up through cables.
- [Hector] This car makes me free.
It's like the nirvana of the cars.
You are free from gas stations;
you are free from the
check-up every six months.
Re-usability is something
that the general public
has to take into account in
order to be pollution-free.
If we want to have a better
world for our children
or grandchildren, or future generations,
we have to be part of the solution.
So, I believe the best way to
start something important
for the world, at large, is
to do this kind of projects.
(car honks)